نعم على بوابات هذا المعبر تحطمت وما زالت
تتحطم احلام اكثر الراغبين في الخروج من
غزه الى مصر فلل العبور اثمان باهظه يكشف
التحقيق الذي نشرته صحيفه لوموند الفرنسيه
جانبا من معاناه سكان القطاع ويستعرض
بالارقام ما يشبه اتاوات العبور التي لا
مغادره للقطاع لمن لا يدفعها لشبكه من
الوسطاء ووكالات الاسفار انتعش نشاطها في
مصر اكثر من ذي قبل منذ بدء الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه تقول الصحيفه ان
الهروب من جحيم غزه في ظل الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه يكلف ما لا يقل عن
7000 دولار يشير التحقيق الاستقصائي
للصحيفه الفرنسيه الى ان الوسطاء يبيعون
تصاريح الخروج للفلسطينيين بمبالغ تتراوح
بين 4 و500 دولار و100 دولار اما
المواطنون المصريون فيضطرون لدفع ما بين
650 دولار و100 دولار يوضح التحقيق ايضا
ان وكالات الاسفار تروج لخدمات التصاريح
عبر الانترنت وينقل عن احداها انها تتقاضى
7000 دولار من الفلسطينيين و12 دولار من
المصريين بينما تحدد مبلغ التصريح
للجنسيات الاخرى ب 3000 دولار نقل التحقيق
تصريحا لرئيس هيئه الاستعلامات المصريه
ضياء رشوان في بيان صدري العاشر من يناير
الجاري يقول فيه ان الادعاءات بفرض رسوم
اضافيه على الفلسطينيين للعبور من معبر
رفح لا اساس لها من الصحه ودعاهم الى
التنديد بهذه الممارسات لكن التحقيق
يستعرض في المقابل شهادات لفلسطينيين
ومصريين لجاوا مضطرين الى نشاط الوسطاء
للخروج من غزه في ظل انسداد كل السبل
لعبور المعبر امامهم ويقول ان بعضهم تعرض
للاحتيال من قبل الوسطاء خسر امواله بينما
لا يزال اخرون يجمعون المال المطلوب ببيع
ما يحوزون من مجوهرات وممتلكات شخصيه او
بالاقتراض من
اقاربهم باسمائها واسماء ملاكها يذكر
التحقيق بعض وكالات الاسفار التي تعمل ضمن
هذا النظام ويقول انهم مرتبطون بشبكه
مصالح مع وزاره الدفاع والمخابرات العامه
المصريه